bonsoir nous sommes le 9 avril 2015
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction est dans l'actualité
yvelinoise aujourd'hui l'institut vd
comme comprenez véhicules décarbonés et
communicants et de sa mobilité fête sa
première année un an de travail autour
et des modes de déplacement de demain
nous ferons le bilan la situation
financière de l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'améliore le
recteur a donc décidé de lui rendre son
autonomie elle peut à nouveau gérer son
budget jean luc vestiaire son président
est l'invité de cette édition la semaine
du handicap se poursuit à elancourt avec
hier soir une démonstration de hand
fauteuil les valides se sont essayés à
cette discipline
cette information tout d'abord pour
débuter la saisie de sept kilos d'herbe
de cannabis à l'hôtel campanile de
voisins-le-bretonneux quatre espagnols
de 25 et de 27 ans ont été ont été mises
en examen mardi l'un d'entre eux a
d'ores et déjà avoué expliquant qu'il
espérait gagner quelques 3000 euros pour
régler une amende pour conduite sans
permis ou tout autre sujet à présent qui
fait rire notre invité jean-luc
baissière dans un instant pour parler de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines mais pour l'instant nous
parlons bien d'éducation mais de cette
mobilisation à l'appel de plusieurs
formations et syndicales lancé
mobilisation interprofessionnelle
partout en france l'éducation donc a été
notamment touchée par cette action de la
cgt force ouvrière solidaire visant je
cite à lutter contre l'austérité ses
impacts destructeurs mais pour les
enseignants il s'agissait aussi de
contester le retrait du projet de
réforme du collège on écoute bertrand en
mesure secrétaire départemental
snuipp-fsu
qu'on arrête de privilégier une certaine
forme de d'économie et qu'on s'attelle à
faire en sorte que l'économie réelle au
service des personnes soit celle qu'ils
soient favorisés et que les salariés de
cette économie tire les fruits delà de
leur travail et que ce ne soit pas
la finance dans son ensemble qui
récupère les gains liés à la
productivité et les fédérations de deux
syndicales vont se réunir à l'issue de
la journée de mobilisation d'aujourd'hui
envisager la suite de l'action
invité ce soir donc jean luc vaissière
président de l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonsoir soit
on va pas parler de cette saisie de
cannabis sont voisins bretons de qu'on
évoquait au début du journal mais plutôt
d'un sujet plus sérieux qui vous a
beaucoup préoccupé ces derniers mois
dernières années c'est la situation
financière de l'université après la
tempête le ciel bleu si elle semble
maintenant se dégager pour
l'établissement lui est ce qu on vient
de retrouver son autonomie financière on
rappelle tout de même brièvement la
situation de l'époque mars 2014 déficit
est de 5,2 millions d'euros l'université
ne peut plus assurer notamment la
rémunération des professeurs un prêt est
accordé huit cent mille euros ça c'est
déjà fin 2013 le rectorat pardon qui
accordait ensuite une avance
remboursable de 2 millions et demi
d'euros aujourd'hui tout ça est derrière
vous et tout va mieux ou on est un petit
peu la situation financière de
l'établissement les choses vont quand
même beaucoup mieux donc il faut rester
comme je le dis je l'écris fois
intelligente mais effectivement puisque
l'année 2014 s'est amené avec ce qu'on
appelle la résultat positif un bénéfice
entre 10 mai de presque 4 millions 7
nous avons pu a brodé au fonds de
roulement avec les départs de l'ordre de
6 millions d'euros on regarde les
résultats 2012 2013 donc on va ça va
beaucoup mieux donc on voit que au delà
de l'aide de deux millions six du
ministère en 2014 on voit qu on fait un
résultat supérieur 4 millions 6 donc
plus elle avance remboursable il s'est
déjà été remboursés non pas encore nous
avons mis ça nous a demandé de
provisionner un quart des sommes qu'ils
ont été alors arrêtés pour
éventuellement rembourser en 2015 donc
c'est ce que nous avons fait dans notre
budget amende et 2015 si je puis dire
alors pour arriver à cette situation il
a fallu faire forcément des sacrifices
des coupes dans les budgets de
fonctionnement des laboratoires les
unités de formation des post je lai
quels ont été les efforts si on peut
revenir à premier tour à l'allemand mais
voilà vous avez tout juste doit
effectivement il ya eu jane l'emploi
c'est à dire je précise n'y a pas eu de
licenciement
et le non renouvellement de contrats
pour les contractuels simplement donc
des emplois de fonctionnaires vacants
sont restés vacants des contractuels qui
ont pu partir ailleurs on n'a pas
remplacé voilà comment ccfl à la
réduction du nombre d'emplois mais parce
que sur deux trois ans on arrêtera loin
une certaine d'emplois qui ont été
supprimés sur 1600 sur 1700
modificatif c'est sur l'emploi voilà
après donc une partie une autre partie
importante sur le fonctionnement
c'est-à-dire d'une part on a réduit
comme vous disiez les dotations de
fonctionnement aux laboratoires aux iut
aux yeux faire aux facultés comme vous
voulez donc de l'ordre de deux trois
quarts par rapport à ce qui était
demandé - ou à peu près 2 par rapport à
2013 donc c'était assez fun assez sévère
sur les recettes des cas parce que le
nombre de composantes ont des ressources
qu'on appelle propre parce qu'il
pratique de l'apprentissage la formation
continue dont il arrive à avoir des
financements par ailleurs donc sur la
nature de la composante est plus ou
moins douloureux c'est donc voila et
puis l'allemand n'avait qu'un mot fait
des économies dans les dépenses c'est à
dire en renégociant des contrats donc
l'appel fameux partenariat public privé
sur le fil est énergique énergétique
excusez moi qu'on a renégocié donc on a
de nouveaux marchés qui sont plus
avantageux donc là aussi on fait des
économies qui sont indolores mais ça
veut dire que l'établissement
l'université dans son ensemble sur ses
différentes composantes a été moins
performante moins compétitives en termes
de formation pro c'est donc je vois rien
de formel et les étudiants en termes de
formation pour site choix qui peut les
motifs on affirme en effet si on a fait
ça on a fermé la filière staps déjà
parlé gp à venir après on affirme eddy
aux sports voilà voilà sans ces
activités physiques et sportives mais
également avec lui des options mais
c'est à dire que chaque étudiant a pu
avoir le contenu de formation qui est
prescrit par le cadrage national si vous
voulez donc et par ailleurs pas votre
question pour répondre une manière de
répondre c'est de voir les succès qu'on
a pu obtenir tant au niveau de la
formation que la recherche on n'a pas
senti à un impact fort cfi katif et de
même une manière de répondre en termes
d'attractivité
voilà je vois pas d'effets significatifs
en d'étudiants inscrits par exemple
cette année sans même envergure
ça a fait partir les étudiants non non
non sont restés dans les eaux ils sont
même venus à ma première année à malgré
la communication qui avait pu être fait
disons fac 2013 qui avait inquiété les
parents bon escient son thème femmes et
lycéens et étudiants sont venus chez
nous et choix par exemple à noter une
autre mesure sur la recherche on voit
que d'année en année le volume de
contrats de recherche qu'on a avec les
partenaires augmente
l'asim positif on a des entreprises s'y
intéresse toujours à cet universitaire
étudiants également mais les économies
vont devoir se poursuivre on imagine
bien pour 2015 pour l'année prochaine
déjà je vous laisse couper votre
portable ce n'est pas grave allez-y les
économies vont se vont se poursuivre
alors bon le salon avait déjà anticipé
le budget 2015 qu'on a qu'on a arrêté on
va dire en décembre 2014 et dans ce
budget on avait déjà promis un petit peu
d'oxygène comme jean précédent le terme
galvaudé d'ailleurs puisqu'on à
augmenter les dotations de
fonctionnement aux laboratoires aux ufr
facultés on a à peu près doublé les
marges de manoeuvre et puis également on
a une petite campagne d'emplois de
fonctionnaires donc d'enseignants mais
également de personnel distractif le
l'objectif étant de résorber l'emploi
contractuel si pour les administratifs
alors que en 2014 est quasiment pas eu
de campagne d'emploi donc voilà donc les
choses repart mais évidemment quand vous
dites comme dit le directeur général des
services de la cité où il ya eu plan de
retour à l'équilibré la pme c'est le
plan de maintien les fibres non il faut
être vigilant c'est à dire que c'est pas
parce qu'on est à l' équilibre voire un
peu bénéficiaire qu'il faut nous allons
commencer à douala ces centrales sont
très très délicate vous récupérez votre
autonomie financière concrètement ça
signifie quoi vous allez pouvoir
justement lancé à des projets vous
tourner vers l'avenir c'était c'est à
dire qu'on a beaucoup plus de souplesse
pas alors que l'année dernière il ya eu
en 2014 à lui à budget arrêté par le
recteur et l'important arrêté par
recteur avec l'accord de bercy pour
faire simple fin mars dans la douleur
et les larmes sur comme on dit et
on a pu faire qu'une modification fin
octobre voilà donc parlante 2015 c'était
plus simple on a pu l'arrêter le recteur
l'a arrêté fin décembre 2014 mais déjà
la semaine dernière on a fait un budget
rectificatif
donc ça on peut régulièrement faire des
busards latifi katif
informer leurs lecteurs merci pour ça un
nouveau simple mais c'est nous qui
sommes et c'est le conseil
d'admistration qui décide qui votent
mais c'est temporaire il ya toujours un
oeil qui est regardé par le recteur et
bien sûr basiques comme normaux comme ça
a dû être créé avant ça deux pas de de
mémoire de président il fallait toujours
envoyer 15 jours avant à votre
connaissance une crise budgétaire les
éléments au rectorat sauf que depuis la
crise ils sont vigilants sur toutes les
identités ils ont dépassé ce sont des
services compétents en la matière donc
et je pense que tu peux rien c'est une
très bonne chose de continuer à
interagir avec les services du rectorat
qui ont des compétences et de moyens
vous l'avenir pour l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
c'est forcément paris-saclay cette
université de paris saclay l us qu sera
une composante plus qu'importante au
milieu de paris-saclay là aujourd'hui le
calendrier c'est quoi cette université
paris saclay elle va prendre forme
rapidement des gens ont du sel
l'arrêté qui publié le 31 décembre fera
des créations 31 décembre 2014 donc
bizarre cité créée on va faire sa
première rentrée en septembre 2015
puisqu'on va accueillir des doctorants
et des étudiants en master voilà mais il
ya d'autres projets vous avez parlé tout
à l'heure de l'attitude vd comme qui a
un lien assez fort avec universal de
grâce à ça quand on exhume ces voitures
de demain qui sont développés sur sur
les yvelines sur le berlin des yvelines
où on va et vient tout à l'heure puisque
avait des comme c'était c'est un nom et
universités est aussi partenaire voilà
exactement et donc on développe notre
présence dans vd comme également sur des
projets collaboratifs avec les
entreprises le bilan pour cette année
pour l'université parce que les
étudiants vont bientôt passer leurs
examens sur cette cette fin d'année vous
êtes satisfait au-delà de l'aspect
financier sur les résultats obtenus j'ai
le sentiment qu'on a des bons résultats
et comme je vous disais tout à l'heure
en terre notre activité c'est même
plutôt mieux qu'avant
bon ou meilleur site est bien valorisée
bien par ses partenaires même si en 2013
est un peu il t'a pas inquiet ou début
2014 et là on voit bien qu'ils sont
repartis
normalement voir mieux mais toujours
répète ça c'est important vigilance un
dernier mois au plus lui dit que
peut-être sur ce jeu qui a été énoncé
c'est peut-être une idée aussi pour
fédérer autour de cette identité de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines game of us qu
dérivé de la célèbre série américaine
l'objectif c'est de retrouver un maximum
de est diplômé de cette université ils
sont quelques 45 mills et ses diplômés
l'idée c'est ça ça se passe sur internet
un petit jeu qui est qui est mis en
place assez assez simple pour retrouver
les anciens diplômés vous voulez créer
l'identité versailles 5 voilà donc faux
possible soit si vous l'avez fait c'est
la fondation de l'université la
fondation qui s'occupe de deux stars
notamment madame vers une créole pour la
cité donc il ya eu l'idée de ce jeu avec
mon s'appuyer sur un prestataire donc
voilà l'idée c'est de fédérer de
rassembler les anciens étudiants pour
éventuellement qu'ils fassent quelques
dons mais je crois c'est important de
créer une communauté ce qui est toujours
un peu difficile dans les universités et
on a quand même pas mal d'anciens
étudiants qui je crois que vous êtes
vous vous êtes un ancien clerc s'était
retrouvé sans voilà qu'on en a d'autres
qui sont qui ont des places avait aussi
intéressante donc on verra pour le don
c'est la forme l'édition frais haché
coupat merci jean luc greciet la
privacité d'être venu parler en tout cas
de cet audit autonomie financière
retrouvée pour lui exclut donc merci à
vous on va continuer à parler d'un sujet
qui va intéresser les plus jeunes ce
sont les jobs d'été un grand forum sur
les jobs était organisée ce mercredi au
centre ariane de vélizy-villacoublay
plus de 500 d'entre eux sont venus
apporter leur cv lettre de motivation
pour trouver donc ce fameux petit boulot
durant la période estivale le reportage
est signée michael et demi d'euros
william el est mathilde capbern
clément à 20 ans il est venu chercher
son premier job d'été je cherche juste à
travailler parce que j'ai beaucoup de
temps libre avant d'avoir une reprise
d'études
j'ai envie de le compléter un peu un
rendez vous annuel très attendu par tous
les étudiants du département le forum
sur les jobs d'été organisé par yveline
information jeunesse propose une
centaine d'offres d'emploi on a une
dizaine de recruteurs présents l'idée
c'est que justement il ya différents
secteurs d'activités qu'ils soient
représentés pour que chaque jeune puisse
s'y retrouver de la grande distribution
aux cueillettes
à l'aide à la personne donc c'est assez
varié il faut aussi bien sûr que ce soit
accessible puisque qui dit jeunes dit
forcément par beaucoup d'expérience
professionnelle au total l'événement
attiré plus de 500 étudiants des divines
ils ont pu déposer cette occasion leur
cv leur lettre de motivation aux
recruteurs venus sur ce forum pour
chercher du travail saisonnier quoi
gagner un peu ma vie
être un peu plus autonome laquelle il
est très bien il n'est bien reçu les
personnes sont super gentils
franchement c'est bien c'est une bonne
idée pour trouver un job facilement jeu
et trouver aussi des idées originales
l'association agricole années fastes
tenait un stand la structure propose des
jobs d'été dans l'agriculture partout en
france ce sont des postes de cueillette
de fruits et légumes vendange
mais pas seulement aussi conduite
d'engins agricoles mois sont donc à une
variété de métiers importante en
l'agriculture qu'elle travaille le matin
bien sûr mais en fin d'après-midi les
soirées sont libres et ils peuvent faire
la fête s'ils sont capables de se lever
le matin bien évidemment parce que les
exploitants agricoles veulent que leurs
salariés soit dans les champs le matin
pour ramasser cueillir les fruits et
légumes ça fait une expérience
complètement différent de ce qu'on fait
de ce qu'on apprend vraiment dans la
campagne et puis en plus c'est enfin ça
peut faire un bon job d'été travaille à
l'extérieur tout ça
si vous avez manqué ce forum job d'été à
vélizy pas de panique vous pouvez
toujours demander des renseignements
dans les bureau information jeunesse du
département à quoi ressemblera le
véhicule de demain dans les yvelines un
institut et réfléchit à depuis est déjà
à plus d'un an vd comme qui fédère
chercheurs dans des entreprises de
l'automobile l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines ou encore des
pme vd com qui vient de fêter ses un nom
l'occasion de faire le point avec
quelques attributs lato et patrick jacq
de 10 km
cette voiture électrique conduite par
anne charlotte nico a une particularité
elle peut aussi se conduire sans
chauffeur un véhicule totalement
automatisées bourré de capteurs qui
prennent tout en charge à la place du
conducteur un peu à l'image d'un être
humain la voiture conduire a besoin de
percevoir son environnement sont des
capteurs de perception qui vous seront
là donc celle ci a une vision à 360
degrés afin de minimiser le risque
d'anglo voire même supprimer
complètement
elle a besoin également de se localiser
ce sont le but des capteurs de
localisation puisque vous avez besoin de
savoir où vous êtes et qu elle l
environnement autour de vous et enfin
elle doit prendre des décisions sans
appel le module de supervision sont
toute l'intelligence embarquée et tout
le coeur de nos algorithmes ce véhicule
prototype est l'une des grande fierté de
bd comme il est testé sur les pistes de
satory institut de transition
énergétique a été lancé il ya un an il
travaille sur toutes les questions de
mobilité d'électrification
d'automatisation et de connectivité des
voitures du futur on a les grandes
entreprises de l'automobile française
qui son fondateur de dvd comme des
grands instituts de recherche
et puis également des pme et bientôt des
start-up donc c'est un écosystème de
près de 40 membres qui travaillent
ensemble tous les jours un mariage entre
secteurs public et privé entre petites
et grandes entreprises entre chercheurs
et ingénieurs qui porte ses fruits
aujourd'hui institut emploie un peu
moins de 100 personnes ils seront plus
de 150 à la fin de l'année et il est
prévu encore une centaine n'embauche
d'ici 2016 pour fonctionner vd com qui
fait partie du pays a le plan
d'investissements d'avenir dispose d'un
budget de 19 millions d'euros ce budget
est en croissance donc sur trois ans et
l'ensemble des bd comme est financé à 10
ans pour
globalement une centaine de millions
d'euros quand l'état met un les
industriels mettent 1 ça c'est le
principe de base du financement de bd
comme reste une interrogation à quand
une voiture sans conducteur sur route
pour l'heure c'est interdit en france et
en europe seul l'état du nevada aux
états unis a donné cette autorisation
pour la google car mais l'avenir
s'annonce radieux pour vd comme en
octobre prochain la ville de bordeaux va
accueillir le congrès mondial des
systèmes automatisés et les responsables
en sont persuadés les derniers leviers
législatives devraient se lever en
attendant vd comme travaille également
sur un pôle d'excellence qui ouvrira la
fin de l'année à satory
pour préparer cette fois les moteurs
électriques de demain
et à quoi ressemble votre véhicule du
futur c'est notre question du jour on
écoute vos réponses alors que mercedes
bien sûr après ça serait une voiture
voyait presque écologique qui fonctionna
j'ai pas à l'eau ou quelque chose de cet
ordre là peut-être plus écolo c'est sûr
mais je vois pas du tout là bas des
voitures conduites automatiquement son
conducteur va des voitures plus
écologiques surtout côté une voiture qui
est fait fixe les accidents
ça on oublie de respecter les distances
aucune idée de la mienne me convient
parfaitement j'ai pas envie d'en changer
désire pas non plus une extraordinaire
moi personnellement mon âge ça me suffit
tout à fait j'aurai 20 ans ou 30 ans de
moins je réfléchirai peut-être
différemment une maison entièrement en
bois montable et démontable en dix
minutes utilisé pour loger de les
personnes en situation précaire c'est le
concept qui a été développé par habitat
et humanisme qui inaugurait hier sa
première construction à jouy en josas
les premiers locataires vont prendre le
possession des lieux dès la semaine
prochaine william l
une maison qui déménage entièrement
composée de bois cette surface habitable
de 40 m² ce montant 10 jours seulement
plus rapide encore le démontage dans
l'essai site que trois le projet porté
par la fondation habitat et humanisme a
été inauguré hier à jouy en josas c'est
une maison 100% écologique c'est à dire
qu'on est sur un produit bois donc
filière bois entièrement l'isolation est
en bois la ouate de cellulose fibre de
bois on a des fondations qui sont donc
réversible avec zéro impact sur
l'environnement en fait du logement
temporaire accompagné donc on accompagne
et des ménages fragiles prenant en
général deux ans dans un logement
classique si bas une maison démontable
pourquoi on ferait pas notre métier dans
une maison qui elle même est temporaire
il ya beaucoup de collectivités locales
mais aussi des entreprises des hôpitaux
etc qui ont des terrains souvent
viabilisés qui servent à rien ou qui
sont en attente de projets ça peut durer
cinq ans voire parfois dix ans parfois
beaucoup plus cependant des cas de
projet autoroutier de choses comme ça
leno à partir de 4-5 ans ben on met une
maison qui est une vraie maison qui
pourrait rester 50 60 ans ce n'est pas
une maison rabais et puis quand on nous
dit que le terrain
doit être récupérée pour son usage
initial eh ben on démonte on stocke et
on va s'installer ailleurs ici le
terrain est prêté par la ville de jouer
en josas pour une durée de quatre ans la
famille bénéficiera d'une convention
d'occupation d'une durée d'un an mais
renouvelable pour un loyer de 280 euros
par mois nous on va l'accompagner un
travailleur social et un bénévole qui
vont l'accompagner
et puis un moment on va estimer qu' ils
sont suffisamment autonome pour intégrer
le logement social classique
va retourner dans le circuit classique
et on va faire entrer notre famille une
première famille originaire de vélizy
viendra occuper le logement dès la
semaine prochaine ce type de logement
peu coûteux permettant d'accueillir des
familles en situation précaire pouvait à
terme devenir une solution pour pallier
au manque de logements hlm
la semaine du handicap à elle encourt
sept ans ce moment des conférences des
ateliers des rendez vous aux sportifs
comme cette démonstration de hand
fauteuil au palais des sports le
reportage est signée mathilde eu qu'à
berne les images et le dis moi
le handicap
un sujet sensible mais pas tabou dans le
cadre de la 12e semaine du handicap la
ville d'elancourt a organisé une
rencontre sportive à la découverte du
hand fauteuil
l'objectif faire connaître le handicap
sous une autre facette l'idée de cette
semaine du handicap n'est pas seulement
parler du handicap ou des handicaps mais
de faire connaître ce handicap à la
population et que les gens puissent voir
que même en étant handicapé on peut voir
des tas d'activités notamment sportives
donc l'idée c'est pouvoir développer une
passion quel que soit le handicap que
l'on que l'on que l'on présente une
passion qui anime michel elle suit
rigoureusement les entraînements
proposés seulement deux fois par mois le
hand fauteuil une discipline encore peu
développé dans le département se
retrouver handicapés se dire on ne peut
plus faire de sport c'est faux donc
pratiquer du sport ce qui m'est arrivé
donc
j'ai été très contente d'intégrer le
club de montigny et de pouvoir faire mon
sport que j'aime le sport que j'aime en
fauteuil pour moi c'est génial moi je
m'éclate et vraiment je passe deux
heures à tous à oublier à m'éclater quoi
à l'instar du handball les règles sont
pratiquement les mêmes à quelques
exceptions près par exemple au lieu de 3
pas autorisée en fauteuil ces trois
poussées et petite particularité tout le
monde peut jouer même les valide à
condition de se procurer en fauteuil on
a pas d andy on n'a pas des valides nous
avons des sportifs parce que les
entraînements sont très difficiles les
joueurs se donnent corps et âme
aussi bien les handis que les valides et
donc
que l'on produit en match c'est du
spectacle c'est du sport en france on
dénombre 12 millions d'handicapés mon
360 milles en fauteuil roulant
pour terminer ce journal les images des
rencontres inter collèges du championnat
d'improvisation c'était au prisme à
elancourt il ya quelques instants aux
rencontres qualificatives pour les
demi-finales du 12 juin est toujours
organisé par la compagnie déclic théâtre
dix collèges s'affronter cet après midi
quatre se sont qualifiés le collège le
village le collège courbet de trappes le
collège einstein de magny les hameaux
ainsi que le collège alexandre dumas à
elancourt tous ont donc rendez vous pour
cette demi finale de juin à la mairie
satrape de quoi laisser le temps à ces
jeunes artistes de se perfectionner
l'exercice et demandent certaines
aptitudes
il ya d'abord une notion de partage de
rencontre c'est à dire qu'évidemment là
on a affaire à des jeunes collégiens qui
ne se connaissent pas du tout qui ne
sont jamais vu donc il faut oser voilà
passé le briser la glace à les
rencontrer des gens qu'on connaît pas
que sont pas de notre collège compas
notre quartier campagne notre ville
après évidemment faut une grande liberté
un peu de folie certainement et puis on
se rend compte quand même qu'il ya le
caractère compte la nature même des
comédiens fin des comédiens en herbe
compte aussi vachement merci d'avoir
suivi ce journal au rendez vous demain
vendredi pour un nouveau point complet
sur l'actualité l'essentiel de la
semaine également tout de suite filets
qu avec florence parfait bonne soirée